lester vasilenko thank you so much for
joining us on upfront uh as we speak you
are in ukraine on the ground there uh in
the capital of kiev what is the
situation there right now
it's uh one of the most tense uh 36
hours that ukrainians have had at least
ukrainians of my age
uh ukraine is at war it's complete war
which is uh firing up uh all throughout
the country russia is targeting both uh
military and civilian targets
uh
we are being hit all from all over the
place on the ground and in there and
also from the seaside
and i guess uh
the ukrainians are still in shock uh
of what we are seeing what we are
experiencing and what we are living
through it's worse than any kind of
nightmare you could have ever dreamed of
you say ukrainians are still in shock uh
until very recently ukrainian president
uh vladimir zelinski was downplaying the
risk of an invasion to avoid panic in a
poll from earlier this month found that
only 20.4 of ukrainians thought that a
full-scale invasion would happen soon uh
did you see this coming
i was hoping this would never come
uh i
have learned in these eight years uh to
hope for the best and prepare for the
worst as did many other ukrainians but
to be honest nothing can prepare you for
a full-on war with the biggest uh
military power in europe third biggest
military power in the world and the
nuclear power
there's nothing that can prepare you to
withstand that on your own
so really when the president of ukraine
uh
was saying that okay
look we're at war for eight years we we
know what's going down uh we had these
threats of escalation and so on
throughout the years all of that was
absolutely true and i mean to have the
population in panic and
in fear would have caused havoc in the
streets and would have actually played
very well
into putin's big master plan to
eradicate independent ukraine from the
face of the earth but instead the
population state bird was uh there was a
feeling of unity which was growing and
that feeling of unity is what is helping
us right now withstand this attack in
putin's speech to announce this attack
on ukraine he talked about how quote
ukraine is not just a neighboring
country
he said that it was quote an inalienable
part of russia's history culture and
spiritual space in that modern ukraine
was entirely created by russia
given this mindset
was there any chance
that ukraine would have a chance to
function as an autonomous
a truly autonomous state
yes and this is what ukrainians are
fighting for and this is why
myself all my parliamentary colleagues
the government the president are asking
of our western allies uh clearly what
putin has declared in his uh crazy mad
speech is a
is a pack of lies uh carefully drafted
for him by uh some
kremlin
masterminds who was an equally perverted
mind and a lack of knowledge about
history whatsoever so uh ukraine is an
independent country ukraine is not
russia
the ukrainian people love their freedom
we fight for our freedom uh we bring our
children up with the love for freedom
and uh this is what we're doing
essentially now we are fighting on the
defensive against an offensive from
russia
to have the right to exist and to live
and i think that um well any nation in
the world and any leader in the world
would be doing the same they would be
fighting for their country and the right
of their country to exist
in that same speech uh vladimir putin
also made the point that nato exercises
have been taking place in ukraine over
the past few years
and he said that military contingents of
nato countries have been almost
constantly present on ukrainian
territory under the pretext of exercises
given that nato has always been used as
an excuse by moscow
do you think that nato's involvement in
ukraine carrying out exercises
but falling short of giving ukraine
actual nato membership uh has it
ultimately hurt the country
look uh ukraine needs nato and nato
needs ukraine in order to stabilize
relations with russia uh that is as soon
as ukraine becomes a full-on uh member
of nato that's it putin has nothing else
to fight for the spears of influence as
he likes to call it uh would have been
decided
and uh
and over and again but uh
but
but respectfully the approach that's
been taken so far that is to say the
nato exercises uh the lack of full nato
membership
did it give
uh putin the pretext necessary to engage
in the actions we've seen over the last
36 hours
if it wasn't for nato putin would have
found another pretext
uh because putin wants ukraine inside of
russia and does not admit an independent
ukraine uh putin is crazy and this has
been proven time and time again starting
from his speech starting from the show
show a trial style uh way he made his
decisions to uh invade ukraine and have
recognition so to speak from his people
to invade ukraine uh
look uh we are dealing with a
psychopathic leader
of a very very big country of a very big
army and of a nuclear state and i think
that the world should really be mindful
of that
and not give in to his lies and his
manipulations and be aware that uh if we
are all to co-exist normally we should
follow the rules set up for us after
world war ii which work
pretty well i guess and when countries
follow them but when one country starts
falling out from those rules it's the uh
responsibility of the international
community
to stand up to it it says so in the u.n
charter which all these countries that
are now uh nato allies uh
they have signed it together with
ukraine so it's not the responsibility
of the international community to stand
up for ukraine because uh ukraine has
done nothing wrong we have made a free
choice as a sovereign state we have not
threatened russia in one way or the
other we have made a decision about how
we act with our own territory with our
own military and who are our partners
russia didn't like it so russia uses its
force and its might to invade ukraine
uh i think you can sort of sense here uh
the
who is in the wrong and who is in the
right like how can ukraine
a much much smaller country with a much
much smaller and less developed army
uh
be a threat
to i'm sorry i repeat myself but uh the
third biggest army in the world and the
biggest army in europe how
yeah we can we can agree that russia is
clearly aggressive uh last week
president zielinski appealed to the
international community as well as you
have just done saying we don't need your
sanctions after the bombardment will
happen and after our country will be
fired at or after we will have no
borders or after we will have no economy
why would we need those sanctions then
multiple countries multiple countries
have now announced that they will impose
unprecedented sanctions on russia
uh do you feel that this is ultimately
too little too late
what are these unprecedented sanctions
where are they i don't see them honestly
the unprecedented sanction would be the
swift why ukraine wants to switch russia
from the swift
swift operations are used with russia to
buy oil and gas oil and gas are the main
commodities resources which feed the
russian economy if they're switched off
from the swift it means that they don't
get the payments for the oil and gas so
immediately we sort of took two birds
with one stone there's also this uh you
know uh isolation of russian markets and
of russia's biggest markets
and uh
clearly this would be the sanction which
would hit the most just switching them
off from the swift and finding another
way to pay for their oil and gas well of
course they won't care about switching
up from the swift in that regard so it's
it has to come together
today uh i think that that the only
right and correct uh both morally and
legally thing to do on the united of the
international community is a provide
ukraine with enough defense capabilities
and actually get contingents here into
ukraine so that we can withstand further
blitzkrieg attacks from russia and two
is to impose such sanctions that would
actually isolate that country or rather
that crazy leader from the rest of the
world because the world does not need to
be poisoned with the toxicity of a
totalitarian regime
in an address to the nation on the first
day of the invasion president zielinski
said we have been left alone to defend
our state
who is ready to fight alongside us i
don't see anyone you've talked about the
kind of sanctions you'd like to see the
type of moves you'd like to see the
international community engage in is
there anything else you need the
international community to do to
recognize to engage in order to see uh
the current crisis in quickly
look the international community can
choose either to act or to continue with
just political statements political
statements are very nice we are very
grateful for them they show uh whose
side who
uh people are on but look when you do
tweet the hashtag stand with ukraine or
support ukraine it's not enough uh you
know it's not going to stop uh the
russian missiles and uh the russian
planes hovering over kiev and the
russian tanks uh moving into our roads
and destroying them completely along
with villages and along with innocent
civilians uh what needs to be done is
really show us uh if you're prepared to
stand with us because you're standing uh
with us not uh not just for the sake of
ukrainians and uh a pretty big country
in europe as well you're standing with
us for your own safety and security what
we need now is actually um
peacekeeping contingents in ukraine uh
since we are not nato members okay fine
fair enough
uh but uh u.n uh with the general
assembly can adopt a resolution on
sending peacekeeping contingents into
ukraine they don't need the security
council for that we can go the same way
that this was done um in korea in 1915.
we've seen pictures of bombed out
residential buildings uh amnesty
international says that it's confirmed
that civilians were killed in a
ballistic missile strike outside of a
hospital uh in uh valhad in eastern
ukraine uh ultimately what would be the
human cost of uh all of this for the
ukrainian people
it will be huge because it's not just
the immediate casualties of war that we
are still counting
but it is also the future of our
children and the mindset with which they
grow up in i'm a mother of three
my oldest is eight years old he's a boy
and already i can see the damage this is
doing to him hearing all the airstrikes
sirens uh seeing all the planes having
to constantly go down and seek shelter
uh
you know
this is what the future ukrainian
generations are going to grow up as was
a lot of psychological issues because of
the war and that has to also be known
and understood but so far about civilian
targets 33 civilian targets have been
hit in the last 36 hours
this is absolutely inhumane and
unacceptable
three of those targets were
kindergartens
children they don't stop at nothing
those people
and i praise the leader
will you stay in kiev
i'm staying because i'm a member of
parliament i have a responsibility to my
people and i have a responsibility to to
my country as a national as a citizen in
ukraine that was born in ukraine that
was raised in key
and also
i have responsibility to my family today
ukraine is mobilized
meaning that everyone who can hold a gun
is fighting and is holding that gun
against the russian aggressors
uh there's no way i can leave for a
whole bunch of reasons lester vasilenko
thank you so much for joining us on
upfront
thank you